goto I want to give you props because I
feel like you've been very instrum
instrument in terms of
uh Bridging the Gap
between Southern California Northern
California Latinos M yeah you know we're
just communicating with each other uh a
lot more conversations are happening uh
naturally you know what I'm saying uh uh
you know and more to come um you know
it's it's going to take some time but
you know you know it's good to
communicate and and get on to another uh
you know far future I was going to say
do you think like in terms of like where
that like just kind of the relationships
of like certain artists with certain
artists from from up north or down south
or even guys like like you like who
you've worked with like like 10 years
ago would any of that stuff have been
possible five years ago cuz it feels
like there's been a lot more putting
some of the politics [__] to the side
and just kind of uniting on on yeah I
mean no it wouldn't have been possible I
mean could could have been but I mean it
would have just been a lot more uh it
would it would have been a lot more I
would say um more complicated and
difficult I think through the times now
and what's going on uh uh in the last
few years within the prison system I
believe has helped out um things to help
develop things in the streets and um you
know there's a lot of Latin that are not
into no type of gangs or no type of
politics that that still feel subject to
uh where they're from yeah just to that
and geographically yeah geographically
and there needs to be some type of now
you know yeah we giving it we're giving
it a chance to we're giving ourselves a
chance to shine a little bit and to work
to work together you know what I'm
saying so you know it's going to take
some time uh you know and it's happening
yeah it's happening right now you in
your podcast you know and I and again I
think I think beyond anything I think
the the thing that's important here is
not we're not trying to do anything
that's just transactional we want to do
things that are
transformational you know what I'm
saying and that's the energy that we're
on you know
Beyond just music like you know really
building something a found that comes
from a foundation of Purity mhm you know
like this is this isn't just about a
monetary gain it's it's much more than
that set an example yeah when we got
together we weren like oh you're from
over here it it it connected it
connected right away you we we have and
we have a lot in common so um
everything's just coming in it's coming
how it's supposed to be we coming at it
how it's supposed to come I want to go
to go back and give a shout out to pocp
Locos cuz that was a
yeah cuz I mean they put on a lot of
Latinos from everywhere I think our
tacos man this guy's hey
man bro we're in the middle of the
podcast where you
at the door locked the door is locked a
[__] okay s give us the wi go my bad gra
take my phone man my bad okay we're on
the wi angle he got us on the wide angle
we could keep he been calling me and
calling I'm like [__]
man okay tell them you're
coming no I was going to say uh yeah no
pocos per Loos obviously like I feel
like like a Kool-Aid I forget the DJ's
name he up they did a lot for the
culture for sure man a lot you know I
remember Koolaid was a very big believer
in it the big bad Network you know yeah
and you know Ed grew up in Oxnard you
know the Oxnard is heavy with the
culture shout out to the 805 man yeah
shout out to the 805 and you know
Kool-Aid opened that door and we came
and the more they got syndicated the
that the more we got out there so that
was a good plug for us yeah and those
low those OG low rider shows were crazy
I'm talking about like 06 05 07 yanking
cranking you know what I'm saying um
tell me kind of like uh for people who
don't know you have GT digital which is
your distribution Distribution Company
yep and these days there's so many
distribution companies popping up right
everybody's trying to do it a lot of
people try to do it they just can't get
clients well that's what I was going to
say for you like uh cuz I'm really you
know obviously I'm real tight with gazi
and Ne and those guys and as as you are
you do a lot of business with Empire as
well there's companies like like um Dro
kid toor and one RPM there so many
independent Distributors these days uh
what is the what do you bring to the
table that is unique I think that being
my my years of being in the record
business you know black and brown
entertainment there Latin records
knowing how to be a record label and the
the the necessity of communication
dealing with the artists people do want
to give you their life of their heart
and then all of a sudden you got to talk
to an email and you can't speak to
nobody you know with us I have staff
we're going to talk to you I talk to you
I listen to the music I'm I'm in tune
with everybody and there's a lot of
artists out there you know what I'm
saying but I I'm able to uh decipher who
really wants it and who is necessary of
that time to talk to him of course
everybody is and we do I believe there's
enough time in our day to talk to
everybody that's the whole thing I don't
you know we want to talk to you I Le
give you five minutes chop it up with
you see what's going on how are you
doing with your marketing what do you
need help in let me listen to your best
song first thing I do what's your best
song right what's your best let me see
it you know what I mean that ain't
nothing this what I'm doing I'm in the
music business I want to listen to the
music you know there's some people that
there's other companies that don't do
none of that that is true you got to
send an email you got to yeah that's it
this your kid ain't listening to your
[__] t for sure they think them
[__] they is not listening to
your [__] they don't give you you just
loading it up putting it in you going to
get they going to get their money they
going to pay you that sh is it hard
though like uh trying to be accessible
to
everybody you know what actually it
ain't n yeah they ain't because most
people most I'm going say most artists
are only doing an album or
two so they they're putting they some
some [__] they forget about
they even put something up right you
know what I'm saying then you got some
that are seriously into it and then you
you could talk to them they're going to
put something out I mean it's it's you
know like I said 10-minute conversation
is going to go a long way yeah I think
that's what he does different you know
because like he was talking about the
communication I think when there's
communication with comprehension it
changes the dynamic of just
communicating when you communicate with
comprehension you understand what you're
talking about and I think he's really
good at that he's really good at letting
them know like look this is a b and c
this is the way it's supposed to happen
you do your part I do my part everybody
wins instead of like oh my shits out all
over the you know in every platform
right so what